the fundraiser for Daniel Penny the man
who was arrested on manslaughter charges
for trying to stop a violent individual
on a subway train it's cracked over two
million dollars currently around 2.3
million dollars with several prominent
individuals donating large sums to make
sure that this man does not go to jail
and that we win this fight on the right
to defend ourselves and as many many of
you know I was a bit critical on the
idea last week well I've come around and
I'll elaborate further in the actual
segment we get to but I personally have
contributed twenty thousand dollars of
my personal funds to Daniel Penny's
defense because I had a change of heart
due to several arguments that I heard
and just generally sleeping on it
thinking about it and then
um assessing the situation and what it
means to actually win this the simple
version before we get in everything is
just that if we win this it's another
major culture War Victory with an
opportunity to win